saviez-vous que pour l' tuuge 3 le
château de voisin à Rambouillet avait
servi de palais présidentiel pour cette
dernière case du calendrier de l'avent
100 % évelinois de tv78 nous embarquons
pour un voyage cinématographique à
travers le
département et nous retournons tout
d'abord en 1983 où Jean-Marie Poiret
s'est installé au vaisinet pour tourner
papi fait de la résistance il y capture
l'essence de ces villas cossu occupé par
les Allemands chaque scène de ce film
est culte avec des acteurs tels Thierry
Lermite Christian Clavier ou encore
Jacqueline mayant il me fait mal à la
som nous changeons de registre en 1995
avec la haine Mathieu Kassovitz
s'installe à Chantelou leving il aura
fallu 2 mois de préparation d'immersion
au plus proche des habitants pour nouer
le lien grâce notamment à une
association les messagers des
précurseurs en matière de prévention
urbaine on termine ce tour d'horizon
rapide avec sopia copola et
marie-anttoinette tourné à Versailles
louer ce lieu pour 300000 € aura permis
de mettre en scène le Fast de la cours
de Louis XV et de faire découvrir au
public des lieux emblématiques mais
aussi des lieux méconnus